faussée de leur industrie. On a
un repormionneurs,mionneurs,mio,
qui lui refuse d'être associé à
tout cela.a.
- François Harding se prépare
à se joindre au convoi
des camionneurs en compagnie
de quatre autres personnes.
L'entrepreneur en constructiquia
d'abri ce week-end pourla manif.
- Les casseurs on n'en veut pas,
on veut
on veut que le message passe,
on veut que les gouvernements,
à un moment donné,
ils arrêtent leur tyrannie.
il veut montrer sa solidarité
aux camionneurs et exprimer
son ras le bol des mesures
- Moi quand je m'en vais au
magasin, puis que je me fais
demander un code QR, je me sens
pratiquement comme en prison.gle
les camionneurs non vaccinés
qui reviennent des États-Unis à
s'isoler pendant 14 jours a mis
d'une entreprise de transport.
DOMINIC GOUDREAU
propriétaire, DG Express
- Le pourquoi que il est où le r
de continuer... que cet employé-
là continue à travailler?
Là il va être privé 14 jours
- Il ira manifester avec une
dizaine de camionneurs de
sa compagnie.
- Le gouFaudrait que ça arrête,.
- Si certains se disent
sympathiques à leur cause,
d'autres le sont moins.s
pouvoir avoir une liberté
comme ils veulent, puis qu'ils
demandent puis qu'ils disent,
puis arrêtez d'en parler!
- De nombreux camionneurs
Québécois qui veulent se joi
au convoi prendront la route
demain mains partiront
de la frontière américaine
à Stans
puis ils convergeront
vers Vaudreuil-Dordreuil-Dordre.
avant de se rendre à Ottawa.
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
Jean Potes à Tadoussac
actuellement. Bonsoir.
- Bonsoir, M. Roy.
- Comment vous voyez, depuis
2-3 jourde se passer au Canada?
JEAN POIRIER, camionneur
- Bien, en fait, moi, c'est sûr
que je suis provaccination.
Puis, au départ, déjà, le convoi
pour la mesure obligatoire de
vaccination aux frontières,
c'était déjà quelque chose
que j'adhérais pas. Mais
ce qu'on voit, la situation qui
évolue, les gens qui se greffent
à ça, on est loin du point de
départ. On est vraiment loin.
Il se greffe toutes sortes...
Puis, ça pourrait être un peu
dangereux pour l'image,
entre parenthèses,
du monde du camionnage.
- Vous, vous avez...
depuis le nouveau règlement,
avez-vous traversé la frontière?
Vous dites que vous, vous êtes
vacciné. Comment ça se passe?
Et la question qu'on demande
beaucoup à ces gens-là
qui manifestent, c'est :
oui, mais même si le Canada
levait l'obligation vaccinale,
les Américains en
une pareille, là.
- Exactement, depuis le 22,
les Américains l'ont.
Ce qu'onaucoup,
c'est que c'est différent
d'un poste de douanes à l'autre.
Il y a des douaniers américains
d'autres non.
Donc, c'est rentré en fonction
samedi ou dimanche. C'est sûr
qu'ils sont pas toujours vite,
rentrer les consignes,
mais il suffit d'arriver
à un poste et que ce douanier-là
le demande, on peut pas rentrerl
abolirait cette mesure,
reculerait, ce serait
très surprenant qu'il recule,ma,
ça avancerait absolument rien;
on va se faire barrer,
on pourra pas rentrerpareil auÉ.
- Donc, comment on peut évaluer?
Il n'y a pas eu de sondage
chez tous les camionneurs,
mais l'appui de ce
chez des camionneur que vous,
vous connaissez au Québec,
par exemple, comment
on peut évaluer ça?
- L'appui ferme, à mon avis,
représente le nombre de
camionneurs qui font du US
et qui sont pas vaccinés,
parce qu a commenc a commenc a ,
chez mon employeur, à nous
demander notre preuve vaccinale
à partir du mois de novembre,
parce que ça fait longtemps que
c'est connu qu'on aurait cette
obligation-là, donc il y a à peu
près juste les purs et durs. Les
autres... ça ne change rien dan.
On est vacciné de toute façon,
double dose ou triple dose;
ça dépend des individus.Fait que
autres, d'après mon feeling,
c'est environ 10-15 % des
camionneurs qui doiventapplique.
qui doivent appuyer ça.
Mais ça, c'est l'idée de départ.
Maintenant, on est ailleurs.
Ce convoi-là défend...
c'est vraiment pour défaire
les mesures sanitaires.
C'est vraiment les antivax.
C'est limite des complotistes.
On a une certaine... Moi,
j'ai une certaine crainte
qu'il se passe des événements
comme le 6 janvier 2021 aux
États-Unis. Il y a des gens qui
sont pas camionneurs là-dedans
qui se sont joints à ça.
Il est là, le risque pour nous.
- OK. Donc, vous dites
qu'on est loin du quotidien
de 9 camionneurs sur 10...
qui se passe actuellement?
- Oui, oui, exactement.
Nous, on a rentré l'application
ArriveCAN, ça se fait
automatiquement, c'est pas
un souci, tout est "easy",
c'est déjà dedans. On le remplit
une fois dans l'application.
C'est pas comme un touriste
qui fait des va-et-vient.
Nous, dans le commercial,
une fois, c'est ré
on n'en entend plus parler.
- Merci, Jean Poirier,
camionneur. Vous